(typing)
- Oh, wow.
You guys dug deep.
2011.
(whoosh)
(typing)
(laughs)
Okay, all right.
Listen, I don't want to upset the beehive,
and I apologize in advance.
You can see it was at a time, 2 AM,
I was obviously watching
the Grammys live as well.
I really don't want to upset the beehive.
I'm not trying to get stung, but I said
Beyonce just needs to relax, let loose,
and just, and I know what the word is.
(laughs)
It's just so funny.
The word is fart.
(ding)
I know that the word is fart.
It has to be fart.
If it's not that, I don't know what it is.
But I think it's fart.
Can I reread it?
Yeah.
(laughs)
Oh, that is so funny man.
Oh man, I remember that.
I remember I was watching that.
I think Beyonce is, I've been
to her concert three times.
Three times.
(typing)
I changed the name of my
iPod 2 so when I plug it in
to my computer it says.
Ah.
(laughs)
Okay, all right.
Let me explain this tweet.
You know when you used
to put a banging tweet
and I was just trying to get retweets.
And I'm gonna be honest,
I think I just Googled it
and then made it.
Cause you could do that back in the day.
So I think I changed
the name of my iPod 2 to
I think it's titanic.
(ding)
So when I plug it in
to my computer it says
the titanic is syncing.
(ding)
Oh man, that's really funny,
but it's a bit dark as well.
Okay, it is that.
Yep, the titanic, the titanic is syncing.
It's been 84 years.
(typing)
2011, what was going through
my mind in 2011 you know?
I was just, you know.
(laughs)
The tweets are so different now.
I ask people stuff like
has anyone ever flown
with Air New Zealand?
Like that what where I'm at in my twitter.
Okay, oh my god what is a.
Okay, so I don't know what this is.
I'm really intrigued.
What is this?
(buzzer)
(laughs)
Oh my god.
I don't remember saying this.
Oh my god, what is Asher D a bad mother,
shut yo.
Top boy.
Okay.
Yeah, okay.
That is how long it came out, 2011.
Oh my gosh, man.
We've come full circle, man.
Oh, you guys got a couple on this one.
Got to make some about
four pieces should do it.
Okay, I need a late night shop
that does an hot chocolate,
Dragons Den here I come.
What the hell.
After a night out.
Epic boomshaklaka, epicness boomshaklaka.
(laughs)
It's safe to say I was
going through some stuff.
Gonna make some cheese on toast,
about four pieces should do it.
Yeah, this is back home.
This is how you know.
(pop)
Late night snack, cheese on
toast, living at my mom's house.
(pop)
You could do that, when you
live at your mom's house,
you could be wherever you want.
Okay, they need a late
night shop that does.
I think it must be cheese
on toast and hot chocolate.
I know where this is going.
Yeah, cheese on toast.
(ding)
(laughs)
Look at the time, oh my gosh.
5 AM.
This again, here we go.
(ding)
Cheese on toast after a night out.
Epicness boomshaklaka.
That's how much I like cheese on toast.
I said boomshaklaka.
Why did I say this?
Is this 92?
Who says boom shakshaka, boomshaklaka?
Some here we go, some cheese on toast
and some hot chocolate me thinks.
Oh my gosh, that sounds so British.
Some cheese on toast and
some hot chocolate me thinks.
All right, governor?
I don't know.
Oh, what's this one?
(typing)
You guys got some old tweets.
2012.
Is any good?
I don't know what this is.
Is, hmm, okay,
it's afternoon time,
that shows a lot about me,
I'm not trying to upset no
one on the way home from work.
Let's see what this is.
Is.
(Netflix sound)
(laughs)
Oh that's mad.
Okay, that's awkward.
It's the best.
It's the best thing going, isn't it?
That's so fun, cause I really didn't know
about that old stuff back in the day.
Cheese on toast, fucking hell, man.